alors déjà un petit peu parce qu'il ya
deux semaines a été donné pour mort
cette terrine à la fédé zuma l'a quand
même mérité elle revient quand même
beaucoup mieux à la pelleteuse je
mélange elle a mangé du pudding
signalement par les bien fort à la
manger des puddings à beijing
comment comment elle se lève le matin
elle mange de cuir de pudding comment
vous le savez mais on est pas simplement
job d'être informé par après disait
ça peut pas être un formateur mais là
pour le coup c'est la presse qui nous
révèle que par ses reprises de
tuer le foot de l on a mieux et ce que
l'on peut peut-être dire c'est que
mercredi alors il ya une énorme la plus
belle réception de l'année la réception
des ambassadeurs a été annulé en raison
du conflit en ukraine et alors les
équipes étaient un peu irrités parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'une réception telle
que celle-là 800 personnes quand même
reçu au château de windsor maud et
bénédicte 9 rallonge de la table de la
grande salle à manger ils se préparent
quinze jours à la france donc il a fallu
au dernier moment
trancher toutes les régions tri dans les
caisses et tous inscrit son nom
démission
alors la reine comme gîte et anecdotes
faut que je pense à ça parce qu'on est
en train de monter un documentaire sur
la reine jacques chirac à l'époque était
président doit aller voir la reine et le
jour il doit aller voir la reine il est
avec jean louis debré qui était ministre
à l'époque et jouer d'aller voir la
reine il y va mais il est bloqué par une
manifestation et du coup ils en retard
il a dix minutes de retard énorme ans la
reine doit l'attendre devant dix minutes
de retard n'a rien à [ __ ] la reine
elle remonte dans ces assemblées et du
coup quand il arrive jacques chirac
arrive et jean louis debré et les
arrivées
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tout le monde ne pouvait pas boire
d'alcool parce que ne boit pas d'alcool
l'eau qu'ils buvaient de l'eau ils
pouvaient plus quand elle est parti se
coucher et terre une pièce à côté
lyonnais debré et se sont envoyés des
bières c'est jean louis debré qui
raconte tout ça donc la queen va bien
donc elles à manger du pudding ça c'est
très bien c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle est effectivement donc la
réception était nul et on en comprend
les raisons bien sûr alors on voudrait
vous parlez de charlène donc on passe
vraiment côté monaco maintenant shine
chez très mal qui était parait-il dans
une clinique à 95 milles euros la
semaine c'est vrai ça on va partir de 95
me ça commence à 72 militaires et une
chambre à zurich exactement nous sur la
côte d'or zurichoise un des
établissements les plus prisés les plus
privées du monde depuis cette crise
comme elle a omis apparemment oui
séances de thérapie par jeu moche comme
une seconde nature il y en avait partout
c'est pas possible de dire jean michel
maire émile à des famines victime d'une
grosse arnaque ou en visite
à trudeau
titre miss esthétique c'est
la panne a été quand même pas retombée
j'en suis mais brussels calorifique
justement cielo il est souvent rapides
comme un certain c'est
génial contre jean-michel
il a coûté
un bras de brad pitt par la tutelle à 60
ans dans un emballage d'aujourd'hui pas
pardon estimant j'ai envie de faire un
vrai compliment rien le visage et où
allaient deux des balles étaient très
très
franchement je le pense excusez-moi
bertrand non non pas de charlène zurich
way voilà elle prend des anxiolytiques
ou deux journées voilà aucune actes
pratiqués le nom vraiment de
l'établissement qui l'accueille et alors
elle a toute une une série de soins qui
lui sont apportés elle fait notamment de
l'hypnose dit on mais qu est-ce qu avec
du bien alors voilà ce que l'on peut
voir c'est que cet hôpital là est
vraiment spécialisés certes dans les
problèmes psychologiques et mentaux mais
aussi surtout dans les problèmes de
dépendance on sait que george michael
quand il y avait des problèmes avec la
drogue a aidé par ses parts c'est
l'établissement la route non pas du tout
c'est parce que je vous dise balle
lundi soir pour l'instant non elle
serait elle souhaitait prendre un tour
aux antidépresseurs
sciences politiques elle a pris beaucoup
de médicaments
semblerait que voilà
mais aussi un an le sujet quand j'amène
des [ __ ] en fait on a l'impression
qu'elle n'était pas heureuse avec le
prince et que au final va aller en
dépression depuis déjà des quelques mois
quelques années et que ça commence à se
déliter mais on perd c'est déjà quelque
chose ou pas bertrand on peut dire est
pas trompé en permanence l abonnement
mais on en a une épreuve
il a eu un enfant mais que matthew
wardak dans un avion attendons mais
c'est avant tout un village moi je crois
vraiment qu et on ne va citer aucun nom
parce qu'on risque d'avoir des problèmes
tiana nacera londonnienne et devant le
père tôt il y avait en perdra de
cannabis et à tout le monde il peut se
passer quelque chose il a dans
l'entourage immédiat du prince des
personnes que ça arrange vraiment devoir
jardel dans cette étude est vraiment sa
folie la plancha pour que charlène
mélantois je prends que jacques chirac à
sitra personnes mais en tout cas ce que
je peux peut-être également vous dire
ces légionnaires tous ces bruits oui je
le fis vais nager parce qu'il a trente
où c'est le bruit qui paraissent dans la
presse n'ont qu'une seule visée depuis
le début c'est attendons bien sûr voilà
si on le voit atteindre qui devra
attendre chaque le veulent la
déstabiliser que l'on arrête de créteil
aussi une voie sacrée à tous ces
magazines en moment donné nous disent
avec certitude mais elle est suivie à
l'hôpital princesse grace de monaco mais
oui c'est cela on le voit très bien
vertes vallées d'azur
donc vous comprenez il est très
difficile d'avoir vraiment des éléments
probants avec services ovi que bercy on
a eu l'impression la nativité j'ai là on
dit je ne peux pas dire de nom vous
voulez pas mais dont les débuts après
spipoll le problème pour elle c'est
caroline de monaco pop mais je n'ai pas
dit que c'était caroline j'ai dit qu'il
n'y a pas que caroline pour le coup
alors qu'ils doivent vraiment
non c'est jacky dont
elle est confirmée par exemple pour le
pour avoir été plusieurs fois à monaco
en reportage vous assure qu'il ya des
personnes qui savent très bien qu'elles
s'adressent à un membre de la presse
pourtant ils viennent nous dire non mais
elle n'est pas à la hauteur non mais
c'est nul ouais mais bon ça y est elle
est nulle mais est ce que vous vous y
mettez quand bertrand maintenant que tu
réponds pas la question des blessures et
ce qu'est la maladie un problème de
santé ou est ce qu'elle est juste et
précis parce qu'elle sait pas comment
sortir et qu'on en a marre de la famille
et qu'elle veut s'en aller et que c'est
compliqué à l helvétie livre on a tout
fait pour qu'elle soit dépressive et l
île est lente mais elle est tombé dans
une spirale médicaments hop et les
doigts sur terre quand j'ai compris ce
drapeau rejoint l'allemand pour faire la
demande à ce que ses enfants quittent
également ce qu'elle adore ses enfants
et que pour elle monaco est dangereux et
je le crois vraiment à quoi il doit
véritable dangereuse de l'emploi ni et
caroline à cause de l'emprise à cause
disons du fait que certaines à coups de
kouakou y
aurait tellement mieux fait le job que
charles et oui on a pressenti il ya des
intérêts à monaco qui sont terribles les
bourgi à côté ce sont des enfants de
choeur et moi même pour le coup elle est
vraiment bien depuis d'école fort que
cette liberté qu'elle aurait voulu que
je
prends une question de l'éclairage
presse people qui avait quand même
intéressant c'est que c'est un
personnage c'est très rare que la
semaine dernière vendredi c'est le jour
où les journaux people sortent en même
temps public closer voici le même jour
vous avez public qui dit qu'elle est
toujours à l'hôpital psychiatrique elle
est très mal et qu'elle est en gros
bonne à rien physiquement
intellectuellement et vous avez voici
qui dit que c'est presque presque
presque pardon un prétexte pour ne plus
revenir à la principauté et en plus
emmener ses enfants les deux sont
incompatibles on peut bien dans les
salles l énorme mais en plus prendre ses
enfants et vouloir organiser une fuite
la vérité est la famille voilà détaille
ces familles on ne lui a pas fait une
tasse et elle n'a pas sa place a dit que
monaco est toxique alors que monaco pour
elle est aussi bien pour les jeunes et
une question qu'elle ne regagne pas
monaco je n'y crois pas une seule
seconde pour aller ou en afrique du sud
je vous rappelle que toute sa famille
vidé mais à monaco dans la commune
limitrophe
dernière question quand même parce que
c'est très important on sait que depuis
voilà sont à son internement nicole
coste donc la mer illégitime d'alexandre
des maladies se pavanent paraît-il à
monaco et pour ça le vis très mal aussi
celle ci il est adulé money où devait
être charlene il ya donc deux enfants
dit oui en effet il ya tout voilà toute
cette engeance là qui entourent charlène
et kibaki profite du fall aura elle
donne unitaire joue un match génial dans
laquelle est dit mais je ne fais aucun
scoop je ne vous balance le cobra second
parce que et fogiel qui appelle je pense
que bfm s'est très mal passé ma vanne à
regarder un petit peu bfm quand même
mais après la mini clips par bos clément
et en même temps sans rien dire elle
nous balance quand même que charlène
apparemment aurait profité d'une absolue
albert pour déloger son fils est allé là
le reloger dans l'oeil des domestiques
qui ne ferait que charlie notre première
dame de monaco et gouvernante aussi le
cap et légère elle même et chambres dans
kohler septime charlene je
suivrai je ne les ai pas eu l'air je
vous attends je ne vais pas toucher
avant de me livrer vraiment une vraie
enquête et de découvrir tout ça je n'ai
pas été gêné tg j'ai pas toujours été
tim schaaff où tu descends à monaco là
descend monaco vas-y mais je vous ai
rarement vu à ce pour remonter une vraie
colère ça l'a pas dit leur colère
caroline que vous détestez mais n'ont
jamais non parce qu'à elle assume le job
divinement est en cours bien qu'elle est
là le blanc d'oeuf rahmani qu'une mini
cela qui me tente vraiment acquis
à
qui tu en veux à personne j'en veux aux
systèmes au système dont ils font
système royal d'avoir mis charlène dans
cette position-là moi d'accord de très
belles vous en avez déjà beaucoup dit et
je ne vous prendre pour votre votre vie
vous sortez d'ici avec une fatwa
londonienne louis juste d'ailleurs on à
la prochaine une du prochain closer
juste là ouais voilà
[Applaudissements]
lui le rencontrer pour de vrai hamilton
il ya le couple magique aussi afida
attendu à ça l'ex sa fortune oh la la
oui alain sur le coeur tu mettais un
autre tu m'étonnes mal à ça me va
photomontage
une grosse frites
michèle torr et son nouveau boyfriend
justin justin bieber est né le 4 mars on
a pill vingt ans d'écart 4 passes 94
plus longtemps des cadors on avoue on my
way six essais ici on a vu que saragosse
la conclusion de tout ça c'est une
rencontre et jamais vos idoles mon idole
à moi absolue c'est lewis hamilton
très bon jour mais quand j'ai rencontré
voilà j'étais à monaco je marche à côté
lui et je sais ce que je peux avoir un
juste à une photo une photo il me répond
pas il marche i marsh qui marche d'une
photo et son garde du corps arrivés dit
tu ne touches pas tu ne lui demande pas
seul dieu parle à lewis hamilton dieu on
y
voit là et si tu veux faire une photo tu
t'éloignes tu l'as far marchands alors
je marchais comme un tir à côté du
marché à six vitesses 4 j'essayais de
faire la photo c'est ridicule merci
quand même c'est fou non ça reste mon
idole faut pas inventer son idole on est
toujours déçu avis à ceux qui
m'attendent dehors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci